the penultimate question this is a lot
of pressure
it's a good thing she's adorable right
you know
you know that we're judging your
questions right that's okay and i'm not
judging you i'm at peace with that right
because i'm not at peace with him
judging me did you have enough carrot
juice to make you a peaceful
peter yes i did actually have 92
references to carrot juice
i did i actually have to go back and get
more
i'm running low what are some
see another multiple parter what are
some go ahead
what are some of the most important
questions a screenwriter can ask
themselves
when developing a story idea
how much is it worth
ten points for each that doesn't get you
to a hundred
you know i i think one one important
question is
how universal is it and
you know you may be having the most
esoteric story
but if it touches everybody it's a
universal story
if it's very very narrow then then it
doesn't and so you're always saying
how are people going to relate to this
can anybody find something
in this relationship i'm creating in
this conflict that i'm creating that
they recognize something
and hence that's why you asked the the
mother-daughter
premise for the book because you figured
most people can relate well this is a
generic
old old premise starting with my sister
almost everybody has had a mother
yeah i think i think i think it was uh
it was chosen because you could i don't
know your background
yeah because you could do your born
teacher well
she's a child of a single mother she
told us that
if you'd been listening um i have a
slightly different take on that
i i believe in the stephen sondheim
dictum that the more personal a story is
and i don't mean by that
autobiographical
then the more it matters to you the more
universal it's going to be
and um but both things are valid it
depends on the writer
i will tell you that if you try to write
something commercial
you will fail every time out for example
when die hard was a success there was
one
there was one movie after another that
came out with that kind of
you know none of them were as good as
die hard and
and then but but for every movie that
came out like that
you know hero in a in a trap place
trying to save the world whatever it is
with a sense of humor uh yeah with this
that's very important
uh there were hundreds of scripts that
were written that never saw the light of
anywhere so i i believe that you have to
write what you want to write
and look at look at what go ahead make
my day did
you know hey everybody try to come out
with that and that wasn't a new concept
when when they when it was written i
mean the
bullet i was a bullet worked same kind
of idea bullet was a more stylish cop
but
uh the dirty harry movies are great
they're really well made they're kind of
the
the detective version of the the
spaghetti westerns you know
but having that one cool line yeah a key
moment
but today i don't think one coal line is
gonna make a great movie
why i think it was also the right actor
for the right time for the late
60s you know um
but i think the other thing you need is
patience well all the things we've been
talking about today
the the ability to tolerate um
ambiguity what
ambiguity he likes that word because
nobody else understands it
um to tolerate failure
to tolerate having to get up and try
again the next day
no no writing career can ever be made on
one script
um i don't there you know i really
believe that you've got to write a lot
and not judge it those are all
we've talked about all this before but
yes those are the things
and then of course being willing to show
your work
no we have to show you work if you're
just going to put your work in a drawer
and you're just doing it for your own
pleasure well that's fine but then don't
say you want to be a professional
writer i'm waiting for the 19 part last
question
well there was a follow-up to this okay
that's so
cheating the follow-up is
the penultimate point two you said that
most films could be based on or or the
popularity could be based on one line
like i'm paraphrasing but go ahead maybe
or
yeah the hook or you know frankly my
dear i don't give a damn something like
that
but yeah but that had nothing to do with
the plot of the movie that was just
that was character that's just character
right but you don't feel that today
could be well you still they want a hook
before they want to hear the premise
before they want to hear the story
so we use in something we're working on
now we used
back to the future you know uh the hook
would be
uh a young boy goes back in time
to prevent his to make sure his parents
get married so he'll
continue to exist i mean that's terrible
i can't remember what we use
that's a hook that's not a premise yet
it's an idea for so to me a hook is it's
it's an idea for a story um
you know what you know it's not yet you
still haven't developed the story
the thing you brought in earlier about
the two brothers
is much more developed than that
but in terms of a line sort of living on
past the film
oh you mean why do you know why the
lines live on
past the film are we beyond that no i
don't think we'll never be on that uh
be beyond that i mean you gotta you get
uh memorable lines
uh as recently as when harry met sally
what's the line you remember
oh i'll have what she's exactly you know
that line was improv
it wasn't even a scripted line that was
rob reiner's mom that's karl ryder's
wife
but wasn't that from the 90s yeah i mean
so i mean anything
to do oh you're saying now well i mean i
mean
yes there's one in a recent movie that i
don't know have you guys seen get out
yet
not yet on the list i think writers are
always trying to write those lines
and they're usually really
self-conscious and awkward this
wasn't because this is a movie the only
thing i can tell you about the movie
it made it was made for nothing and the
guy was famous before he made it the
directors
can feel it's wonderful he had that show
on
on uh on comedy central
and he knows everybody and but this is
his first direct this is his directorial
debut
and the movie wasn't expected to do well
and is one of the most successful movies
of the year
and there's a great line in that i think
will live on past the movie and that's
the premise of the movie is a a white
girl takes her black boyfriend to meet
the parents
that's not what the movie's about at all
but that's all i can tell you it'll ruin
the movie for you
but the father the first thing the
father says to the to the black
boyfriend
is actually played to my wife's
consternation by a british actor
he says you know i would have voted for
obama for a third term
now that line is brilliant it's also
in character it has to do with the movie
but it's so witty and it's so true
that that like liberals like embarrassed
liberals you know when they want to say
something good in their
around black it's part of what the movie
is about that he
that people will i mean he said in an
interview that he gets that all the time
from white liberals that you know
well wish that i could have he could
have had a third term
you know uh but they're trying to show
you how liberal they are
so yes i think that i think peter's
right i think we'll always have those
just like willows in paris but it's just
it's just bad when you see it
self-consciously written
like i think i've just written that line
yeah
well you know hopefully you're a good
enough writer to see that and take it
out you know
um the other thing that really bugs me
in
in writing is when the writer makes a
reference
that obviously doesn't belong in the
period or they're trying to be too
contemporary you know too
contemporaneous they're trying to be too
hip you know so they'll make a joke
about something that nobody would have
made a joke about
and i see that all the time i've
probably done it
many times but
again a great line is great it's great
for advertising for
but doesn't make a great movie you know
uh bruce there's so many lines in die
hard but that's not why the movie was
successful
i have a theory about why that movie was
unique and successful
he wasn't there to save the world he was
there to get his wife
out of the building and that's what made
it human
you know and and a lot of these like
speed which was a big success which
followed it
was such a contrived situation you know
a bust
that if it goes below you know a certain
you know it'll blow up
i mean come on and then they manipulate
you by having
the old trick which is everybody's use
of having the partner killed
which raises the stakes which can work
it worked great for
um oh come on help me out um
lillian hellman's boyfriend who was
blacklisted um
you know great mystery writer well it's
been used in a zillion movies yeah but
who was it he was the guy who did it
better than anybody
in uh um the
movie about the the birds um
like you know where there was something
in the the stuff that dreams are made of
is a classic line that we'll always will
always know
that's from uh maltese falcon oh okay
what line was it yeah um it's the stuff
that
you know when he sees what's inside the
birds you know it's the stones or
whatever it is he says
he's you know it's the it's the thing
everybody's the mcguffin that
everybody's been looking for and he says
ah the stuff that dreams are made of
that's great right
and and then the other line in that
movie that i love is i'm not going over
for you sweetheart
meaning i'm not going to jail for you i
love that movie it's so well written
dashall hammett thank you for helping me
so much i'm always there for you
you